34 000 in crypto and then i have five
ethereum
and we're gonna hold hoddle
hold on for dear life do you have any
crypto right now in your
sizable portfolio i have none none
what are you holding on to right now
just just stonks
you're a piece of [ __ ] you have like
you're like my mother my mother had like
one share of mcdonald's
my mother would get one share of a
company she'd be like i have one share
of exxon
yeah she had like stock certificates in
a book she had like
one share of a company or like two or
three shares of a company
it's amazing but you're not that much
better than that no
no no no no our criminal friends devin
and ida own uh a small
purse crypto a little wallet right a
couple hundred bucks
i think they have a couple hundred
dollars and they watch the crypto market
like like our friend ida watches the
market
like her life depends on it
and she's just on the edge of her seat
watching this
and just reading and studying she could
make so much more money on only fans
just show the cash
but she's trying to learn about uh
cryptocurrencies and central banking
central banking show your ass
she's attractive stop talking about fiat
currency
show your feet and earn a living
now i keep telling her that
i've told a lot of my friends and i
don't mean anything nasty by this in
fact i wish someone would tell me this
but we know why they're not going to
because you know i have a very
i have a specific look i told many of my
friends you should become a prostitute
you should have sex for money are you
not
listening to me well i'm thinking about
well the fiat current have sex
with strangers and have them
pay you
are you not understanding what i'm
saying
you're good-looking enough it is a
compliment yes
to tell someone that they can [ __ ] for
money
that is a compliment and if and i've had
people get offended when i've said that
people have been mad at me because i
have told them
that they should start a little a little
at a time not like dive
in but like begin to think about
transitioning into being a [ __ ]
and they're angry at me they're actually
people have had
really bad reactions to that
piece of information which is very
logical
nothing wrong with sex work at all and i
think many people need to get off your
high horse
and and and let's get realistic
and get it and do it now before you lose
value in the marketplace you know
before you and men and women and and
non-binary people we're talking to
everyone
i'm telling most of you to become
prostitutes
that that fit a certain and even if you
don't there'll always be
like i could be a prostitute but it's
for such
a small sliver of the population
like it's for a it's like people will
[ __ ] me but to pay to [ __ ] me
you it's gotta you have to have a real
fetish
and it's a small segment of the
population
but if i marketed myself appropriately i
could do it
but so this but some of our friends are
very attractive
and there's no reason that they're
talking all the time
and they're trying to understand the
world and how it works
when they could be taking photos and
videos of themselves
putting different things in their ass
is that wrong
imagine if that was your work day and
you could kind of do it
you have a look where you could do it
truly
if you wanted to become a prostitute you
would make more money on this show
like if you had an only fans what would
i do on only fans
show your dick the problem with you is
you have no
you you're you're you're very good
looking but you're
like you're you're like a dullard and
you're
you don't like your brain doesn't work
so what it is is like the
the people have to create the fantasy
completely themselves because you you
you kind of like
you look like you're a kid that like
like when you were
young like you heard a lot of loud
noises
and you have that that type of so when
you
you look at someone you don't know how
to be like it's sexy
it you just you're not fully developed
in
in that way like emotionally like like
maturely
you don't i don't know if you can really
like turn it on and
but you can just do it with photos you
just get your dick you just jerk off
on only fans do a video of me swinging
it
yeah if you have a big enough dick where
you can swing it around which we all
know that you have a big dick
um if you can swing it around i don't
know if you can really swing it around
i mean you keep saying on bigger dicks
you can can you really like swing it
like that
i mean what are we talking like like uh
i don't know what to do
how much what are the tears like david
and goliath like the the old school
slingshot like that
i don't know what you're saying using
biblical references we're talking about
practical applications of what you can
do
the problem is you you when you when
people look at you
you're not there you're somewhere else
all the time
and the people want you to be kind of
there
you know what i mean yeah and i can't
really do a neck down thing
why because i don't have like a good
body like i don't have like i'm not
ripped
no it's not great but it's
fine enough it's fine for only fans
right
but you just you just have to
change the way you like interface
you know or maybe people might be into
that like like uh like
because there's a lot of like i don't
know if
that could be a fantasy like a like a
big dick autistic
like caretaker and an airbnb
like or you're like a groundskeeper with
a big dick it's
autistic like i feel like people would
want that
and that's not if i'm not trying to
offend you i'm just telling you
that's a better life than what we do
here
it's truly a better life
i see all these people out here doing
comedy starting podcasting god bless
them
but i look at some of them i go hey just
you want attention you could get it a
lot of different ways you know